yeah uh let me try to
okay great all right so uh yeah
um uh next we have bill fefferman
from chicago who will be telling us
about uh noise versus and precision and
the hardness of
uh random quantum circuits okay great
thanks uh thanks so much for the
introduction so uh it's great to be here
virtually today to tell you about the uh
the hardness of random circuits
uh this work will be based on two joint
works with my berkeley colleagues the
first is
is based on joint work with adam boland
uh chinmaynirky and umeshwazarani and
the second paper which is very recent is
based on joint work with adam boland
zeph landau and yoon chao liu and the
second paper you know just appeared on
the archives like a few months ago
um so the starting point for this talk
as i think many of us know is that the
first quantum supremacy claims have now
been made we've seen
you know several of these already uh
including some in the last few weeks
uh you know but the first one was uh was
by google in late 2019
who implemented the uh random circuit
sampling proposal
on uh 53 cubit uh um
you know as 53 super conducting qubits
uh and then more recently by a quantum
optics group
at ustc who implemented the gaussian
boson sampling proposal in late 2020
so in this talk we'll give the latest
complexity theoretic evidence to believe
that these experiments
might be solving hard problems for
classical computers
so we won't settle all of the problems
but we'll sort of get as far as
as we can okay um and i'll kind of bring
you up to the uh the frontier of what's
known and what's not known
uh so okay so from a uh physical point
of view these two experiments are
completely different right that is
roughly speaking
what constitutes a qubit or a quantum
gate
it's completely separate uh but they
have a shared
theoretical framework they're both
solving random quantum circuit sampling
problems
in other words the hard problem is to
sample from the output distribution
of a randomly chosen quantum circuit
drawn from some distribution
okay which we'll describe in a moment so
the
initial theory goal which has been a
goal for you know almost 10 you know
probably more than 10 years now
uh and still has not been resolved is to
prove the impossibility
of an efficient classical sampler
algorithm that's a classical
algorithm that essentially tries to
simulate an idealized version
of the quantum experiment so what that
means is it should be given as input a
description of a random circuit c
with an output distribution d sub c
that's if we measure all the qubits
right uh and then the classical
algorithm given this
circuit description should output a
sample from any distribution
x that's close in total variation
distance to d
sub c with high probability over the
choice of c
okay so we're trying to show that no
such classical sampler
algorithm can exist to sample the output
distribution of a random quantum circuit
that's the goal um so let me now
describe
what you know google's ensemble of
random quantum circuits
um you know to say what we mean when we
say a random quantum circuit
uh so what they do is they generate a
quantum circuit
c on m qubits on a 2d lattice with
around
square root n layers of horror random
nearest neighbor gates
so each layer might look something like
this you know the circles are qubits
the edges here are uh horror random
two-qubit nearest neighbor gates
well this is a single layer the next
layer could look different for example
you know we could we could uh uh you
know connect horizontal neighbors with
our gates instead of vertical neighbors
um what we do is we start with the all
zero input state on all the qubits we
apply
uh you know the square root n layers of
our random quantum circuit
and then we measure all n qubits in the
computational basis
to get a sample from the random circuit
okay so how do we prove that this
sampling problem
uh is is hard for a classical computer
well
we can't do it yet but all of our
current methods start in the same place
which is we first make use of well-known
reductions
that were due first to stockmeyer in the
mid-80s
which say that if our goal is to prove
the hardness of sampling
uh from a random circuit then it
suffices to show that
giving a certain additive estimate to
the output probability
of a random quantum circuit is sharp p
hard
okay it's a hard problem uh so so
graphically
we think of stock meyer's reduction as
working as part of a proof by
contradiction it sort of works as
follows it says
let's say for the sake of contradiction
there does exist
a classical algorithm that samples from
the output distribution
of most random quantum circuits well
then there's another algorithm
and what this other algorithm does is it
uses an np oracle so strictly speaking
it's not an efficient algorithm
but it sort of computes output
probabilities in this non-standard sense
in other words giving a certain additive
estimate to the output probability of
most random quantum circuits
so our goal is to show that this problem
is sharp p
hard this problem on the right this
estimation problem
which would then say that it's very
unlikely you know unless the ph
collapses that there should be a
uh you know an np algorithm an algorithm
that uses an np oracle to solve this
problem
and therefore because of stockmeyer's
reduction there cannot be a classical
sampling algorithm
okay so before i go on let me just make
it stop for
briefly and ask if there's any questions
about the basic framework of what we're
trying to do
okay cool so let me then go on uh let's
make this conversation a little bit more
uh precise
so i'll start with a really simple
definition i'll call the output
probability of a quantum circuit
this quantity it's just simply the
probability if we start in all zeros we
apply our random circuit
and then it's the probability that uh
you know when we measure all
n qubits in the computational basis we
see all zeros again right so that's p
zero of c and we'll stick with this
notation throughout the talk
okay now the main subject of study in
this talk will be what i call the delta
random circuit estimation problem
which is given as input a circuit c
output
an estimate q to the output probability
p
zero of c with imprecision delta
uh with probability two thirds over the
circuit
okay so you so this is just formalizing
what i told you about in the last slide
it turns out to prove
the goal of hardness of sampling using
stockmeyer's reduction
it suffices to show that the delta equal
one over two to the n
problem is sharp p hard the reason one
over two to the n is so important
is because for google's ensemble of
random quantum circuits
this is the size of a typical output
probability
okay now we can't show this we've been
trying for the last 10 years
but we've been getting progressively
stronger results um
so with respect to a circuit c on n
qubits and throughout this talk i'll
think of the size of the circuit as
on the order of n times d where d is the
circuit depth
uh you know in our original paper on the
subject we're able to show that the
delta equal
two to the minus o of m to the fourth
problem was hard
uh movasogin proved this to two to the
minus uh o of
m to the third and very recent work
we've been able to improve this
dramatically to 2 to the minus
o of m log m but we're still not where
we need to be
which is 2 to the minus n
so now what i'll say is in the case of
boson sampling with this which is this
linear optical proposal for quantum
supremacy
cern it turns out that very similar
hardness arguments take us
even closer to the goal of proving the
boson sampling conjectures
so that is with respect to a boson
sampling experiment with n
photons and m equal n squared modes uh
you know in um in 2011 in their original
paper aronson and arkapov were able to
show that the delta equal one over e to
the end of the fourth
problem is hard in our recent paper
we were able to improve this to 1 over e
to the 6
n log n and now the goal changed and it
changed in our favor the reason for that
is because the size of a typical output
probability in a boson sampling
experiment
is 1 over e to the n log n so
you know we're only off by a factor of 6
in the exponent after our very recent
paper um
and it seems so close especially if like
me you've been working in this area for
10 years and
and you know sort of the best we can do
now uh but we think we've hit a barrier
which is sort of frustrating
in other words um you know to do any
essentially any better than what we've
done
uh we think we'll need dramatically new
proof techniques um
and we'll talk about this more toward
the end of the talk
okay so let me give a road map for the
rest of the talk first i'll sort of
review
our our result from 2018 um
and you know the hardness result and and
to do this we'll first discuss
lipton's average case hardness result
for computing
the permanent of a random matrix it's a
beautiful result and it will also serve
as a template
for our discussion of of random circuits
and then
we'll adapt lipton's result from the
permanent to the output probability
of random quantum circuits um we'll see
that in many ways the permanent
of a matrix is a similar sort of uh you
know
mathematical quantity to the output
probability
of a random circuit and then we'll prove
uh
we'll show a result from our very recent
paper which is that
which proves that these results are
robust to uncorrected depolarizing noise
um in a certain well-defined sense and
this robustness
um actually will give a barrier against
improving our hardness result to larger
imprecisions delta
so in other words uh you know as i said
before what we'll show
is the fact that we're getting this
robustness to sort of
uncorrected uh physical noise will
actually tell us that
to improve our result uh to larger
imprecisions we're going to have to have
dramatically new proof techniques okay
let me take questions before i launch
into the sort of technical part of the
talk
okay great so if there's no questions
let me keep going uh so let me describe
uh lipton's proof of the average case
hardness of the permanent of a random
matrix this is a
classic resulting complexity theory due
to dick lipton from the early 90s
a very beautiful result very simple but
but clever result
uh so i guess the starting point is that
the the permanent of an n by n matrix
is sharp p hard in the worst case right
that's a famous result uh
in complexity theory due to leslie
valiant
which says that essentially if i can
compute the permanent of of
an n by n matrix for any matrix say over
a sufficiently large finite field
then i can compute the number of
satisfying assignments to a boolean
formula which is a hard problem
now how do we boost this worst case
hardness
to the the stronger notion of average
case hardness
right so to do that we'll use a simple
algebraic property
of the permanent which is that it's a
degree n polynomial
in n squared variables the n squared
variables here are of course the n by n
matrix elements
um the matrix entries all right so
here's the setting of average case
hardness
we want to compute the permanent of our
favorite worst-case matrix
x over our field some arbitrary matrix
but we only have access to a faulty
algorithm o
that correctly computes most permanents
over the field in other words this is
what o does
it takes as input a random matrix y and
its
output agrees with the permanent with
probability
one minus one over poly over the choice
of matrix
but for one over poly fraction of the
matrices why
you know the output of o could be
completely uncorrelated with the
permanent
okay so how are we going to use this
faulty average case algorithm
o to correctly compute the permanent of
our favorite worst case matrix
well this is what lipton does it's sort
of a polynomial extrapolation idea
we're going to choose n plus one fixed
non-zero points in our field we'll call
them t
one t two through t n plus one
and then a uniformly random matrix r
in the field and then we'll consider the
line
a of t which is x plus t times r
right so we take our worst case matrix x
that we want to know the permanent of
we shift it by something random now
there's sort of two simple observations
which once we're done
sort of well once we we say them they
essentially spell out how the proof
should go
right the first is what we call the
marginal property which says
if we look at each ti individually well
a of ti is a uniformly random matrix
over our field
because we took a fixed matrix and we
shifted it by something random
and so what we got is a is a uniformly
random matrix over our field
and the second observation is that you
know there's this univariate polynomial
property lurking here which is that the
the permanent of a of t is a degree n
polynomial in the single variable t
uh and of course this is inherited from
the algebraic property of the permanent
which says the permanent
itself is a polynomial uh of degree n
all right so now we're essentially ready
to see how the proof works
right the point is by the fundamental
theorem of algebra
you know this permanent of a of t is a
degree
n polynomial and so these n plus one
evaluation points you know permanent of
a of t1
permanent of a of t2 and so on right
uniquely
uniquely define the polynomial so we can
use polynomial extrapolation techniques
to recover
the coefficients of the polynomial
permanent of a of t
from these n plus one evaluation points
and
then once we have that it's it's trivial
to see how to get back the permanent of
x
we simply evaluate our polynomial at t
equals zero because when t
is equal to zero well a of a of zero is
equal to x and so
the permanent of a of zero is equal to
the permanent of x
okay so this is how lipton's proof works
let me again
stop briefly for questions in case you
you have them
uh in observation one you're saying that
it's uh uh uniform
uh uniformly random yes absolutely
and there is one question in the q a uh
i'll just read it
it says is there any reason for the
average case complexity you've used of
lipton yeah because we're going to adopt
it in a moment for random circuits
i hope i understood that question
correctly
anything else
okay great so let me continue so how are
we going to adopt
uh lipton's proof um from the hardness
of the
of the permanent right the permanent of
a random matrix to the output
probability of a random quantum circuit
um well like i said before and so in
many ways i think these two quantities
um you know the permanent and the output
probabilities are sort of similar
mathematically in particular they both
have this similar algebraic property so
much like the permanent
the output probability of a random
quantum circuit
has polynomial structure so to see this
let's consider breaking apart our
circuit
into its gates so let's say c is equal
to cm
times cm minus 1 and so on these are say
two qubit gates well then the polynomial
structure comes from the feynman path
integral
which allows us to write the output
amplitude
of the circuit as this enormous sum over
exponentially many paths
but the value of each path is the
product of
m gate entries so it's very manageable
quantity
um and and so not surprisingly this is a
polynomial of degree
m in the gate entries of the circuit
right and and by the born rule the
output probability what we care about
p zero of c is a polynomial of degree
two m we just square the amplitude
okay so how can we use this this
polynomial structure to
to sort of adapt lipton's proof in this
new setting of the heart of the output
probability of a quantum circuit
here's one idea won't quite work but
it's very close to working
so let's say we we choose and fix m
har random two qubit gates we'll call
those big h
h1 big h2 and so on um
and now let's consider a new circuit c
prime
uh which is sort of a scrambled circuit
so you know what we're going to do is
we're going to take each gate in the
in the worst case circuit that we want
to know the output probability of
uh we'll call that ci and multiply by h
i the i
the ith gate of this horror random uh
you know there's this har random
ensemble that i
that i made and we'll notice that by the
invariance property of the horror of the
har measure
you know we've taken a fixed gate and
multiplied it by something har random
and so the output is completely har
random right and of course this is
the sort of the analog of lipton's
marginal property
right remember lipton in his proof took
a fixed matrix
x and shifted it by something random to
get a new sort of uniformly random
matrix
that's very much the equivalent of what
we're doing here we're taking a fixed
circuit and we're shifting it
uh so to speak by multiplying it by a
horror random gate
but the sort of problem here is that
unlike in lipton's case
uh you know we've sort of scrambled too
well there's no univariate polynomial
structure
that allows us to connect the worst case
circuit c
with the scrambled circuit c prime this
new scrambled circuit c
prime is completely independent of where
we started
completely independent of c so it's not
at all clear how to do something clever
to you know to extract the output
probability of c
from output probabilities of c prime
okay so we we need something a little
bit more and to do that we'll do
something we call
correlating via quantumness um so we're
trying to find the lip the analog of
lipton's univariate polynomial structure
which allowed us which allowed him to
essentially
extract structure out of randomness um
right and and the main idea that we
propose to do this is to implement a
tiny fraction
of these two qubit horror random gates h
i
inverse in other words here's the new
way we're going to scramble
we'll let the ice gate of the scrambled
circuit ci
prime be ci that's the ice gate of the
uh worst-case circuit
times h i uh again the i f uh har random
gate
times e to the so so far that's the same
thing as what we did before
right and that didn't work so the new
thing here is we're going to multiply by
e to the minus i little h i
uh theta where little h i is the log of
big
h i and theta we think of is something
that's non-zero but tiny
very small uh and the point is that this
has a lipton-like structure to it
right if theta is equal to one right
then you know so if theta is not small
if it's equal to one then the
corresponding circuit c
prime is exactly equal to our worst case
circuit
c why is that because if theta is equal
to one we've just gone and implemented
h i inverse and h i times h i inverse is
the identity
so we get back that each of these gates
c ci prime is equal
to ci so we again recover our worst case
circuit c
but if theta is really tiny then each
gate is close to her random it's close
to her random
because if theta is really tiny we've
done essentially nothing right
um you know and so the the circuit
ensemble should be essentially random
so now we can we can try to use a
similar uh proof structure
what we would do just like in lipton um
we would take several non-zero but small
angles
theta uh and apply polynomial
extrapolation so in other words what you
would do is
fix uh you know theta one theta two
through theta
m plus one right because the degree of
the polynomial is
m you know what you do then is is uh
is compute the output probabilities of
of these sort of scrambled but
correlated circuits and use some sort of
polynomial extrapolation argument
to recover the output probability of the
worst case circuit c
now this is very close to working
uh but it's not quite right and it's not
quite right for a very simple reason
which is that
this this quantity this circuit e to the
minus uh this gate e to the minus i
h i theta it's not a fixed degree
polynomial in theta
it's um and so the solution that we
proposed which is a bit subtle i think
is to take the fixed taylor fixed
truncation
of the of the taylor series for e to the
minus little h i
theta e sorry e to the minus i little h
i theta
in other words here's the final way we
propose to scramble our circuits which
has sort of
all of the properties to recover
lipton's style proof
so in other words each gate in the
scrambled circuit c
prime is ci times h i again it's
completely scrambled
but now instead of implementing e to the
minus i h i theta itself
will implement the kth order taylor
series truncation
of this gate okay and now it has what we
want so why is that well because each
gate entry
is a polynomial in theta because the
taylor series is a polynomial
in theta and then by the feynman path
integral
right so is the output probability of
this truncated circuit c prime
right so now we can do exactly what i
suggested before we can use a lipton
style argument we fix
m plus one small thetas
and then extrapolate to recover the
polynomial in theta q of theta
and then compute uh theta at one which
by the way we've set things up
is equal to the output probability of
our worst case quantum circuit c
okay before i go on let me take any
questions
okay no questions about our our proof
here
there's a question how do you how do you
take this capital k
i assume that means how do you set like
how large should capital k be
and uh it can it should just be some
polynomial
because you know you fix it
okay great so let me uh let me go on so
the subtlety here uh is is sort of to
motivate these these truncations right
let's
sort of think about what we did um you
know what what we did here is we
uh you know to introduce we introduced
these taylor series truncations to get
some polynomial structure that allowed
us to
use a lipton style of argument to show
the hardness of
you know the average case hardness of
computing the output probability of
these circuits
but in so doing we changed the
distribution over circuits and in fact
this new distribution over truncated
circuits is
is supported over over circuits that are
actually slightly
you know slightly non-uniform they're
non-uniform because we
you know we took the taylor series and
we truncated it right
um but so why how do we motivate this
how do we motivate
showing this hardness result for a
different distribution
over truncated circuits well the key is
to remember
back to the stock meyer reduction you
know in other words our goal was not to
prove the hardness of exactly computing
the output probability p0 of c but
rather in computing
a good additive estimate to within
imprecision one over two to the n
again because the goal was not was never
to prove hardness of computing
it was to prove hardness of sampling and
this was the error that was lost when we
when we sort of went from one to the
other
um and so what our result is is proving
is it's proving the hardness of
computing the output probability
of a slightly non-unitary truncated
circuit
p0 of c prime which is nonetheless
extremely close
like exponential and k uh close to the
output probability of the original
circuit c
c and so what i see is our main
uh sort of technical result from this
2018 paper
sort of motivated the truncations as
follows
what we prove is that with respect to
this additive estimation this order of
one over two to the n
additive estimation well estimating the
output probability of the truncated
circuit
is hard if and only if estimating the
output probability
uh to the same imprecision of p0 of c
the original unitary random circuit
is hard so in other words while strictly
speaking there's this small difference
between the truncated circuit
uh distribution and the and the original
sort of unitary distribution
um you know what we show is from the
perspective of of of hardness of
sampling
right there's no difference at all okay
so that's that's sort of uh how we
motivated this and intuitively because
the truncation error that we're sort of
making when we truncate the taylor
series at a fixed k
order is so much smaller than the size
of the additive
error where conjecturing is hard if you
look at my interval picture what we're
doing here
is uh you know showing hardness here at
p
0 of c prime that's the output
probability of the truncated circuit
it's exponentially close you know uh to
p zero of c the harder the output
probability of the unitary random
circuit
uh but then we're making this conjecture
that outputting anything in this much
wider sub interval of with two to the
minus
n over poly is sharp p hard and our
result is saying
you know look if if we're going to make
this conjecture it shouldn't really
matter if we're starting at
p 0 if the center of the interval is p 0
of c
or you know very slightly close to it at
p 0 of c
prime and we formalized this in our
proof uh
but you know one thing that we did
technically speaking is we left open
the hardness of exactly computing the
output probability
of the unitary random circuit c um and
this was uh
filled in in subsequent work by uh by
ramis movasag
in 2019 and 2020 uh who who
sort of adapted our proof strategy still
use the sort of lipton style
extrapolation argument to go from the
you know an average case to a worst case
and so on
uh but but does so in a slightly in a
different way
that sort of maintains unitarity when
he's extrapolating so he never has to
leave
the uh the unitary group when he's uh
when he's going from his average case
when he's extrapolating between his
average k
circuit the random circuit and the worst
case circuit
okay uh once more any questions about
the the
um these results
great so now we've reached 2021
and in our recent paper we've been able
to improve the robustness of these
results to additive imprecision
to greater additive and precision so and
one thing i'll say right away is that
this was this same result was also
obtained
uh independently um by uh by
simultaneous work of condo
mori and movison so here's the theorem
just to remind you what i
claimed earlier so i claimed it's sharp
p hard to output an
additive estimate uh to the to p zero of
c
for a random circuit c to within
imprecision two to the minus m log m
right so um this is an exponential
improvement over what was known before
which was
on the order of you know two to the
minus of m cubed okay
so now let me let me tell you the main
technical lemma that allows us to
conclude that
um so uh here's sort of the setting okay
we're given as input uh a certain sort
of description
of a polynomial of a sing a real
polynomial of a single variable
q of theta of degree m but we're not
given
a sort of a typical description like you
know we're not given for example the
coefficients of this polynomial
uh instead we're given on the order of m
squared
sort of faulty evaluation points to this
polynomial
where these points are sort of equally
spaced in some narrow subinterval
of the unit interval 0 1 which we call
zero beta i'm going to think about beta
as
like around 1 over m the degree
and you know we know and another thing
that we know about these points is that
at least two-thirds of them
are delta close to the evaluation of the
polynomial
right so in other words graphically it
sort of looks like this
um you know we there's this polynomial
uh
q of theta which is maybe this black
curve here right
but we're not given it explicitly as
input instead
what we're given are these sort of
faulty evaluation points these red dots
here and what we're promised is that you
know most of these evaluation points
should sort of hug the curve to within
you know their delta close to to the
evaluation of the polynomial the black
curve
but then one third of the points like
these these three points out here
uh you know are completely off right
they're
not even necessarily correlated with uh
with with with the polynomial
and what we show is that using these
faulty points
right there's an algorithm it uses an np
oracle so it's strictly speaking not
efficient
but what it does is it outputs z which
is an additive estimate to the
evaluation
of the polynomial at one you know way
over here at one to with an imprecision
delta
times two to the o of m log beta inverse
where because of our setting of of beta
you know beta is equal to one over m so
this is delta times two to the o
of m log m with high probability
okay so so in other words what this
algorithm does is is something like this
it's going to output another polynomial
it's this uh this blue polynomial the
guarantee we'll have about this blue
polynomial
is that it will agree with a potentially
different two-thirds of these of these
red points
and what we show is no matter how these
these this polynomial is is outputted by
the algorithm
uh you know we show that the uh the
evaluation of this polynomial at one
is sufficiently close to the evaluation
of the original polynomial this black
curve at one
and i'll say this is an exponential
improvement
uh over prior work um in in the
following sense
in in terms of beta so the prior work um
you know had a linear dependence in the
exponent in terms of beta and we improve
it to this logarithmic dependence
again in the exponent uh and so the
upshot of this
is that if delta is small enough right
if these if these good points are
sufficiently close to our our polynomial
then what this is saying is that you
know if if the delta for example is on
the order of
one over two to the m log m we can use
these faulty evaluation points
to estimate q of one the the polynomial
at one
uh which is a hard problem it's a hard
problem because we think back to our
prior construction
and we've encoded the output probability
of our worst-case circuit c
in q of one so that's a hard problem and
what we're saying
is even computing these faulty
evaluations
right as long as delta is sufficiently
small like one over uh
two to the m log m is as hard as
computing the worst case point which is
sharp p
hard okay again let me stop and just
make sure there's uh
if there's any questions please ask them
so the bad points can be chosen the
value can be chosen necessarily right
right exactly
okay so this uh so maybe we should well
okay maybe i can
maybe wait for two one more minute just
to see if any any questions are
sort of materialized here
okay great so then if there's no
questions let me keep going um
so you know so far in our discussion
we've talked about the hardness of uh
you know of imprecision
right but not a physical noise um and
you know physical noise is
is is very important of course for a
near-term quantum experiment because we
know that
without error correction uh you know the
noise
eventually overwhelms the signal right
so for example in
in google's random circuit sampling
experiment that they did on 53 qubits
uh you know they estimated that uh their
fidelity was something like
0.2 and 99.8
noise with every indication that if they
made their system size larger
you know the noise would uh would would
continue to overwhelm and the fidelity
would be suppressed exponentially
um and so you know there's this really
interesting question which is how can we
model
this sort of uncorrected near-term noise
from a theoretical standpoint for random
quantum circuits
well one way to do this is by
considering a fixed noise model
a fixed physical noise model so for
example um
you know with respect to google's
ensemble of of random quantum circuits
a very natural uh sort of modeling of
their noise
is is to have each random gate of our
random quantum circuit
ci followed by a two qubit depolarizing
noise channel
uh so this is the uh this e i here is
the depolarizing noise channel on
two qubits with say some noise strength
gamma which we think of as some small
constant
okay so another way of thinking about
this
is we can think about choosing a noisy
random circuit
by first picking our ideal gates in the
circuit so just like we did before in
the noiseless case you know
these are cm cm minus one and so on from
the random circuit distribution so for
example
maybe these these gates ci are har
random uh
two cubic gates uh and then the
environment or you know something that's
not up to us
chooses the noise operators and from a
distribution i'll call
script n which is specified by the
channel so for example to be clear about
this
in the case of two qubit depolarizing
noise
these operators and are sort of
uniformly chosen to qubit poly operators
right uh and then at the end of the day
when we measure our random quantum
circuit
we get a sample in all n qubits uh we we
get a sample from the output
distribution of what i'm calling
n dot c by this i mean sort of an
abusive notation dot here
is gatewise multiplication of the ideal
gates in the circuit by the noise
operators
without ever learning what the noise
operators are right so this is sort of
the
traditional sense that we talk about
noise in sort of an error correction uh
scenario
sort of an unheralded sense where you
never learn uh you know the identity of
the noise operators
um and so the point of this which i
think turns out to be quite
quite interesting is that you know very
similar hardness arguments that worked
in the noiseless case actually work
almost directly here in the noisy case
uh and the point is by the linearity of
the noise channels
we can write the output probability of
the noisy random circuit
as this expectation value we're
essentially averaging over the
uh you know the identity of the noise
operators of the
output probability of the joint circuit
n dot c
right or written another way we're we're
uh you know
we're writing this as the expectation
over n of the output probability of this
sort of p
zero of n dot c um and the key point
here
uh which is really quite simple is that
this can be written as a weighted sum
of feynman path integrals right i'm just
writing out what this expectation value
is um and you know it's it's a larger
more complicated sum than the
uh the noiseless case but the key point
is that the property that we wanted
to establish our worst to average case
reduction still exists here you know
which is that this is a polynomial
of degree 2m in the ideal gate entries
so we still have
this polynomial structure and so by
essentially the same arguments as we as
we sketched before
we can prove a worse to average case
reduction over the ideal random gates
c for computing the output probability
of this noisy random quantum circuit to
within the same
uh imprecisions within two to the minus
o
of m log m okay now this is just a worst
average case uh reduction uh over the uh
over the ideal gates in the circuit
so the the interesting question another
interesting question is you know how
hard is the worst case of this quantity
right and to to show that this is hard
you know that computing the output
probability of a noisy quantum circuit
is is is hard in the worst case right uh
we can rely on a nice result of fuji who
shows that this quantity
is also sharp p hard to compute in the
worst case
providing that the noise rate gamma is
some sufficiently small constant so as
long as it's
a constant that you know that in other
words it doesn't depend on the the uh
the number of qubits n but in general it
would depend on the uh the architecture
of the
of the random quantum circuits right so
so uh
so we actually have hardness here in the
noisy case and and i think the
the key reason i'm so interested in in
this result is for the following reason
okay in the noisy case unlike in the
noiseless case
there's also a trivial classical
algorithm for computing output
probabilities
and the issue is is is quite uh
intuitive it's that you know if we have
uncorrected depolarizing noise in our
circuit where you know we keep
alternating layers of random gates with
depolarizing noise and
we don't correct well that's going to
cause our output distribution
to rapidly converge to uniform as the
system size grows it's again it's
intuitive it's just saying that you know
if you have
this depolarizing noise and it's not
being corrected you're sort of ins
you're adding entropy into your system
and eventually if you keep doing this
without correcting for your noise
you know you're going to reach uh the
maxillary mixed state or the uh
or the uniform distribution um and you
know as i always like to say in my talks
it's it's clearly not hard to output a
probability of the
from the uniform distribution you know
even i can do this it's it's one over
two to the n
right and so the the really interesting
question
uh is how accurate is this trivial
algorithm that is supposed to give an
estimate to the output probability of
the noisy random quantum circuit
that trivial algorithm just outputs one
over two to the n
um well we don't know we've been working
on this
uh in in my group uh very intensely but
there's sort of a conjecture which
appeared in the context of the google
experiment so what google conjectures
uh is for random circuits this trivial
estimate
uh you know succeeds or rather works
with with imprecision
two to the minus o of m um or by the way
this big o is hiding the noise strength
okay gamma which is some small constant
um
and in fact we thought a lot about this
we can prove it in certain sort of
simplified toy models of random circuits
that that uh this convergence is this
fast
but i think what i the reason i think
this is so important is as follows i
claim that
uh this sort of provides a noise barrier
um
toward improving this any these hardness
results to any further
precision any better precision uh why is
that well what have we really done here
what have we accomplished
so let's recall so on the one hand in
sort of the first half of the talk you
know we established that computing the
output probabilities
of a noisy random quantum circuit of
size m
is hard to within imprecision two to the
minus m log
m okay these were our new results
but then on the other hand we think it's
classically easy
to solve this problem trivially within
imprecision two to the minus o of m
okay so what this is saying is that in
the noisy case
the hardness result is essentially tight
you can't hope to improve this
this hardness result more than by a log
m factor in the exponent
since we have easiness at imprecision
two to the minus o of m
um so the upshot here which i think is
is relevant
even to the noiseless case you know it's
especially relevant to the noiseless
case is that if we want to dramatically
improve this robustness in the noiseless
case
say to get a hardness of sampling result
you know to to make this 2 to the minus
n the number of qubits uh well we need
to
invent new proof techniques that are not
robust to noise
right the fact that the same proof
techniques worked in the noisy case as
the noiseless case
is a problem because we know that the
noisy case cannot be extended much
further
and so you know we need to find uh
genuinely new techniques
uh that are not robust to noise if we
want to improve these results
essentially any further
okay great so let me uh conclude um so
what have we done we've improved the
imprecision to additive error of
computing the output probability of a
random circuit of size
m to additive error two to the minus o
of m log m
uh now what we showed is that this
hardness remains if the circuit is noisy
but in this case we think that the same
imprecision is essentially tight
up to a log m factor in the exponent
okay and uh and so as a consequence even
though it seems like we're getting
closer and closer
to the imprecision that we would need to
settle you know the quantum supremacy
conjecture and improve hardness of
sampling of a random circuit
we think that to get essentially any
further we'll need dramatically new
ideas dramatically new proof techniques
thanks a lot let me take questions
yeah any quick questions before we move
on
looks like there's a question in the
chat which is for boson sampling would
your argument about noise be the same as
the case of google depolarizing noise or
would it be different for boson sampling
that's a great question the answer is it
would be very different depolarizing
noise is a good model it turns out for
google's experiment in fact if you read
their experiment they
they're very clear about this that they
really think a very good noise model is
this sort of
local depolarizing noise um you know but
but for bosom sampling it's really not
the right model
uh you know the the for example in bozen
sampling in most bozon summit
experiments by far the predominant
source of noise is photon loss
right and we're actually i'm you know
where we're studying
uh sort of the equivalent phenomenons in
the case of photon loss what
what's how quickly do you converge to
something trivial like say the vacuum
state
right we don't we strictly speaking we
don't know uh
but we're sort of hoping to show similar
style results that it should be sort of
exponential in some parameter
uh that's meaningful to the experiment
great anything else
okay so uh let's thank bill very much
and um
our next speaker
our next speaker is nicholas 100